welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host definition aka
the guy that's sweating like kevin feige
right now and
dc fandom has just been completely
relentless with its updates
and i totally skipped over this one and
it's something that i definitely want to
talk about
now the flash panel was earlier in the
day and i wanted to see how
things went with the schneiderker and
ezra miller's thoughts on that basically
to kind of give context to this
now we do have a new image of the flash
costume
which is more of a sort of organic
um sort of textured thing they described
it as and what
flash is basically going to be doing
with this is he's going to be breaking
the barriers of time themselves
traveling into the universe uh sort of
creating a multiverse
from that in which he'll encounter a
different version of batman
and also erase some of the other things
now we don't have this for definite
but personally just i the way i see it
is michael keaton's obviously
being picked for a reason to be batman
and
that they are doing a recast i think
with ben affleck
now they don't want to get rid of henry
cavill they don't want to get rid of
aquaman jason momoa they don't want to
get rid of gal gadot
so personally i see it as this is just
correcting the timeline which flashpoint
is often used for
and they're basically going to do a
recast but explain how to do it again
don't know for definite a lot of people
have disagreed with me on that
totally respect your opinion and i hope
you can see where i'm coming from on
that
now this costume and they did mention in
the snyder curt panel
that flash was going to sort of be
exploring the way to to break
the quantum barriers of our universe and
that his suit was going to be used for
that
he gets he get he gets tempted basically
what happens with flashes if you don't
know with flashpoint
he realizes that he can change time and
the first thing that he wants to do
is go back and save his mother from
dying
which completely understandable however
there's
the butterfly effect um the multiverse
theory
multi-worlds theory by david deutsch and
lots of things that cause issues with
this
including spiraling timelines and he
gets stuck in one of these
um with basically a different version of
batman
now they haven't said whether it's going
to be jeffrey dean morgan
personally i think it will be i think
the way that the film will work
is that ben affleck will be at the start
flash will go back in time
meet thomas wayne played hopefully by
jeffrey dean morgan
and then he'll arrive back in the
present after
fixing the timeline and letting his
mother die which is when he'll come
across michael keaton and realize that
things have just changed slightly
if you've read flashpoint you know what
kickstarts a new 52
and basically i think that's what
they're gonna do here they're gonna sort
of take
you know ben affleck in my opinion wants
to say farewell
and i think they're going to use that
for this again could be wrong i was
wrong about ben affleck coming back so
happy to be wrong on that i absolutely
love the guy now
this is the costume here and as you can
see
it's it's very organic and the power is
sort of coming from his suit and then
spiraling out into to the waves and
it's a great it's really nice concept or
i do think it looks great silhouetted
against the the orange background
and i appreciate its use now the the
image that we really need to talk about
though
is this concept art with michael keaton
now
michael keaton one of the best batman
of all time personally my favorite is
ben affleck
and then probably you know kevin conroy
might be there too but michael keaton
absolutely nailed the role
and the thing is he never really got to
to quite close off his character
he wanted to do batman forever um tim
burton wouldn't return
michael keaton decided not to do it
either uh
so it's great that we can finally get
some closure
and he he gets to to basically play the
part that
i think a lot of people love him for you
know
i i was born in 1988 batman came out in
19819
sorry um it was one of the first films i
ever watched
absolutely incredible blown away by this
and they did talk in the panel how
ezra miller bumping into grass grant
gustin's version of the
flash sorry it's been a long day grant
gustin's version of the flash
has sort of opened the possibility of
the multiverse and here
he's discovering michael keaton's batman
so this first look looks incredible
now there were talks that well basically
the report said that michael keaton
would be sort of a mentor figure like
nick fury
in this concept art though doesn't look
like that at all looks like
he looks like he's fighting alongside
flash which i
definitely think is amazing i'll
absolutely love to see him go head to
head with
villains fighting alongside the flash so
this first look if this is concept or on
what the film's going to be like
absolutely over the moon with it and uh
yeah i just wanted to talk about this
because
all of the trailers and everything this
is kind of getting lost
and it really is something special um
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts so comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video
please drop a thumbs up it's been a very
very long day and i
i massively appreciate the support and
the thumbs up on that and
you know thank you everyone for sticking
with me i'm not going to be doing
face videos like this all the time
that's just there's just absolutely no
way i could do this many videos in a day
um editing them and recording the audio
and writing a script
because there's just so many
announcements so thank you for sticking
with me
you've been the best i've been
definition and check out some of our
other videos as well
much love good night
you